[Music]
there's chemistry and then there's these
two well hey i mean there's a lot of
love to go around oscar isaac's gaze
directed at jessica chastain will not be
easily forgotten heck days later and the
internet is still obsessed with their
slow-mo affection let's break down what
happened over the weekend oscar and
jessica were at the venice film festival
celebrating their new mini-series scenes
from a marriage but there's nothing left
to say what is this what is this thing
where we can't talk and once the
co-stars hit the red carpet this moment
came into our lives we see jessica wrap
her arm around oscar's shoulder then get
that look from oscar who then planted a
kiss on jessica's inner arm
oh and apparently he smelled her as well
she smells really good i know she looks
like she doesn't
amazing
which seemingly led to this next part
where chastain laughs out loud and cuts
oscar's face following the antics
the slow motion clip instantly went
viral and social media still hasn't
recovered i got a little star struck on
the carpet over there and we know
jessica is very aware of their moment's
popularity she took to twitter on monday
to have a laugh about all the attention
tweeting a picture of gomez adams from
the adams family
kissing the arm of his wife morticia the
pig bears an obvious resemblance to that
red carpet moment and could also be a
nod to oscar being the voice of gomez in
the new animated film series
why does nobody come in through the
front door mindy kaling had the best
reaction to oscar and jessica's big
moment jessica instagramed this clip of
her festival look and mindy commented
why is oscar isaac the only person
allowed to kiss your inner arm
oscar and jessica recently chatted with
e.t about their close relationship
behind the scenes this is the second
time around for you guys because we saw
you together in a most violent year and
so i wonder if there's something that
you can both tell me about the other
that maybe would surprise all of us
jessica i'll have you go first
um well also too we've known each other
for over 20 about 20 years because we
went to college together
um
so what can i say that would surprise
people about you
[Music]
she smells really good i know she looks
like she doesn't
amazing
um
honestly i don't i can't think of it oh
yes
um
you're i mean it's not surprising well
yes because you're so fit you've his his
dressing room is like just has like
boxes and boxes of potato chips
really
i had a lot of potato chips
food junkies
chips
listen
i'd like to say i'm a connoisseur yes
and i love barbecue so i love barbecue
potato chips and i would never keep that
in my room but whenever i wanted it
there was like one time that um
ariana my friend ariana and i we really
wanted barbecue chips and oscar was
shooting so we went into his dressing
room because we knew that's where the
stash was they stole my chips yeah but
it all stays behind the scenes in fact
oscar and jessica's spouses were on hand
with them in venice oscar's wife elvira
lind was just off camera for the iconic
arm grades
[Music]
you